DON'T LET THEM.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW IS TOM HOMAN,
FORMER ACTING IC DIRECTOR AT A
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
AND FORMER DNC DIRECTOR AND
FORMER COMMUNICATIONS ADVISOR TO
PRESIDENT OBAMA, LUIS MIRANDA.
TOM, BESIDE THE WALL, WHAT OTHER
LEGISLATIVE FIXES MUST CONGRESS
DO?
>> TRAFFICKING VICTIMS
PROTECTION ACT.
WHEN UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN COME
ACROSS THE BORDER, CENTRAL
AMERICAN CHILDREN ARE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY FROM CHILDREN FROM
MEXICO AND CANADA.
FROM CENTRAL AMERICA, THEY GET
ALL THESE EXTRA RIGHTS.
THEY END UP STAYING IN THE
COUNTRY FOR YEARS GOING TO THE
IMMIGRATION PROCESS.
THE MEXICAN CHILDREN AND
CANADIAN CHILDREN DON'T GET.
WE NEED TO FIX THAT.
ALL THE CHILDREN NEED THE SAME
SET OF RULES.
IT WILL SOLVE A LOT OF THE
CRISIS.
>> Laura: UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN.
>> UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN.
>> Laura: THOSE NUMBERS CAN
KIND OF BE STERILE.
THOSE NUMBERS ARE STAGGERING.
PEOPLE ON TELEVISION SAYING THE
NUMBERS HAVE GONE DOWN FROM 2004
AND THEY SHOW THE CHART.
63,000 PEOPLE.
THOSE KIDS HAVE TO GO TO PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
THEY HAVE TO BE CARED FOR.
THEY OFTEN ARE ON FOOD STAMPS,
OTHER PUBLIC ASSISTANCE.
TWO BLOCKS FROM HERE, WE HAVE
PEOPLE SLEEPING IN THE STREET TO
HAVE A SIGN THAT SAY I'M AN
AIR FORCE VETERAN SLEEPING IN
THE STREET TONIGHT.
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
THE OTHER LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY,
160,000 FAMILY UNITS.
A NINTH CIRCUIT JUDGE RULED WE
CAN'T DETAIN FAMILIES MORE THAN
20 DAYS.
BACK IN '14, WE HAD THESE
HEARINGS AND 40, 45 DAYS.
THE NUMBERS WENT DOWN OF ILLEGAL
CROSSINGS.
SOME JUDGE AND THE NINTH CIRCUIT
SAYS NO.
THEY GET RELEASED.
THAT'S WHY THERE'S A SURGE OF
FAMILY MEMBERS RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THEY WON'T BE
DETAINED.
THEY GET RELEASED INTO THE
PUBLIC.
MANY DON'T SHOW UP IN COURT.
IF THEY SHOW UP IN COURT AND
LOSE THEIR CASE, 91% LOSE THEIR
CASE, LESS THAN 2% LEAVE.
IT'S AN OPEN BORDERS AGENDA.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS IT.
>> Laura: THE FLORIDA'S
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT.
LUIS, IT SEEMS LIKE JUST A FEW
YEARS AGO DEMOCRATS BELIEVED IN
BORDER -- NOT WALLS.
OPERATION GATEKEEPER IN
SAN DIEGO.
THAT WAS A BILL CLINTON
INITIATIVE.
I COVERED IT FOR CBS NEWS.
IN 1996, I WAS AT THE BORDER.
HUGE BARRIER, STEEL BARRIER.
THEY WERE ALL FOR IT.
WHAT HAS CHANGED?
>> ONE OF THE ISSUES IS
DONALD TRUMP IS AN EXPERT AT
CREATING A CRISIS.
>> Laura: YOU DENY THAT THIS
IS A CRISIS AT ALL.
>> IT'S A PROBLEM WE CAN DEAL
WITH EFFICIENTLY.
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES AND THE
PEOPLE, WE HAVE THE ABILITY.
>> Laura: WE DON'T HAVE THE
PEOPLE.
I HATE INTERRUPTING YOU.
I DON'T WANT TO DO IT BUT WE
DON'T HAVE THE MANPOWER TO
PROCESS.
>> HE CREATES A CRISIS AND
COMPROMISES AND THEN --
>> Laura: WALKED IN MY ANGLE
DID I LAY OUT --
>> COUNCIL ON FOREIGN AFFAIRS.
>> Laura: RICHARD HOSS IS THIS
-- IN FAVOR --
WHAT'S IN MY ANGLE DID YOU
DISAGREE WITH?
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, DHS
UNDER DONALD TRUMP IN 2017
POINTED OUT THEY ARE AT SOME OF
THE HISTORICALLY LOWEST NUMBERS
OF PEOPLE TRYING TO CROSS THE
BORDER.
THERE DOES APPEAR TO BE A SURGE
IN OCTOBER AND NOVEMBER BUT WE
ARE NOT AT A CRISIS LEVEL.
YES, WE NEED TO DO MORE TO WORK
WITH THE THREE COUNTRIES,
NORTHERN AND CENTRAL AMERICA, TO
MAKE SURE WE ARE IDENTIFYING
WAYS TO REDUCE THE VIOLENCE,
FIGHTS AND CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND PERHAPS WORK
TO ESTABLISH POINTS WHERE WE CAN
HELP WITH THESE PEOPLE SO THEY
CAN REQUEST ASYLUM.
>> Laura: 400,000 PEOPLE
CROSSING OUR BORDER -- I HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND.
I KNOW YOU'RE WELL-INTENTIONED
AND I THINK YOU WANT A SOLUTION.
I GET IT.
BUT HOW IS IT NOT A BIPARTISAN
ISSUE WHEN 400,000 PEOPLE COME
INTO OUR COUNTRY ILLEGALLY EVERY
YEAR?
I DON'T CARE IF IT'S DOWN FROM
1.2 MILLION FROM FIVE YEARS AGO.
THAT'S BAD TOO.
BUT 400,000 PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE TO GO TO PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
THESE ARE INFRASTRUCTURE.
THEY GET A RANGE OF BENEFITS.
>> THEY ARE MORE THAN 16,000
BORDER PATROL AGENTS RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE DRONES FLYING AND --
>> Laura: WHAT DO DRONES DUE
TO PAPER KIDS HIGH SCHOOL
EDUCATION?
>> THE SAME PEOPLE WHO CLAIM
THERE ISN'T A CRISIS OF THE
BORDER CLAIMED THERE WASN'T A
CARAVAN.
WE FOUND OUT DIFFERENTLY.
THERE'S A CRISIS OF THE BORDER.
TWO CHILDREN HAVE DIED.
IF PRESIDENT TRUMP -- IF HE
WASN'T SUED BY THE ACLU AND SOME
NINTH CIRCUIT JUDGE THAT YOU CAN
ENTER ILLEGALLY.
THESE TWO CHILDREN WOULD HAVE
BEEN ALIVE.
>> THERE IS AN IMPORTANT
INCENTIVE TO TELL PARENTS DON'T
PAY SMUGGLERS.
DON'T WORK WITH CRIMINAL
ELEMENTS TAKING YOU ALL THROUGH
THESE COUNTRIES.
THAT'S FINE.
WE CAN AGREE ON THAT.
>> Laura: I DON'T THINK ANY
COUNTRY IN CENTRAL AMERICA
WOODLAWN 4,400,000 PEOPLE.
THEY ARE SMALLER COUNTRIES.
THEY WOULDN'T WANT A   A BIG MAS
THEY WOULDN'T WANT A   A BIG MAO
THEY WOULDN'T WANT A   A BIG MAF
PEOPLE COMING TO THEIR COUNTRIES
WHO THEY BELIEVE WEREN'T INVITED
OR NOT WELCOME.
NO COUNTRY WANTS A FREE FLOW OF
HUMANITY ACROSS THE BORDER.
I DON'T KNOW ANY COUNTRY
PERSONALLY THAT WANTS THAT.
>> THE WALL IS NOT NECESSARILY
THE RIGHT WAY TO FIX THIS.
WE ALREADY HAVE 7 MILES OF
FENCING.
THERE'S DEFINITELY WAYS WE CAN
IMPROVE.
>> Laura: DOES OPERATION
GATEKEEPER WORK IN SAN DIEGO?
>> I DON'T RECALL THE SPECIFICS
OF IT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF FRIENDS THERE
ALREADY.
WE HAVE IT ALL AWAY TO EL PASO.
THERE'S PLENTY OF OTHER THINGS
WE NEED TO DO.
FOR EXAMPLE, MAKING CHANGES
BECAUSE OF THE TUNNELS THEY'VE
BUILT FOR THOSE OF THE TRUE
CRIMINALS SMUGGLERS.
>> Laura: I WILL BE IN FAVOR
OF THAT.
I'M GOOD FOR THAT.
>> SHUT DOWN THE GOVERNMENT AND
HAVE 500,000 PEOPLE NOT GETTING
PAID?
>> Laura: TO HIS POINT, AND
WHILE TAKES A LONG TIME.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE BUILT
OVERNIGHT.
HOW IS IT DEALING WITH THE
CRISIS?
>> I MADE IT CLEAR AT THE
WHITE HOUSE TODAY THAT ONE THING
HE NEEDS TO DOC ABOUT HIS WALLS
DO WORK.
EVERYWHERE THEY'VE BUILT A
BARRIER, IT PLUMMETS.
HE NEEDS TO PUT THAT FALSE
NARRATIVE THAT NANCY PELOSI PUT
OUT THAT WALLS ARE INEFFECTIVE.
NO, THE DATA PROVES THAT THE
WALL WORKS.
WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT
LEGISLATIVE CHANGES BECAUSE
FAMILIES ARE GOING TO KEEP
COMING IF THEY KEEP GETTING
RELEASED.
>> Laura: I DON'T EVEN BLAME
THEM.
>> TRUMPED MADER CRISIS THAT'S N
>> TRUMPED MADER CRISIS THAT'S T
WORTH SHUTTING THE GOVERNMENT
OVER.
WAYS THAT WE CAN DEAL WITH
IMMIGRATION IN THE
CENTRAL AMERICAN PROBLEM.
>> Laura: WHEN THEY COME, YOU
WANT THEM TO STAY.
>> WE HAVE TO ALLOW SOMEONE WHO
WANTS TO APPLY FOR ASYLUM TO
APPLY.
THERE'S WAYS TO DEAL WITH HIS
PEOPLE BEFORE THEY GET TO THE
BORDER WITHOUT CREATING
UNNECESSARY CRISIS AND SHUTTING
DOWN THE GOVERNMENT HAVE A
500,000 AMERICANS WERE NOT GOING
TO GET A PAYCHECK FOR OVER A
MONTH.
>> Laura: THEY HAVEN'T NOT
BEEN PAID.
THEY WILL BE PAID.
THE DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT A
BORDER AT ALL.
ISN'T THAT THE CASE?
>> THEY WILL BE PAID.
>> Laura: YOU DON'T ANSWER THE
QUESTION COMMENT KIND OF REVEALS
A LOT.
>> I SAID CLEARLY WE'VE ALWAYS
PRIORITIZED BORDER SECURITY.
DO IT SMARTLY.
>> Laura: SMART BORDER
SECURITY LIKE SWISS CHEESE.
SWISS CHEESE BORDERS.
[ALL SPEAKING]